the winner of the ftth individual award
is recognized for the importance of his
role in the investment in fiber
infrastructure by his family's
investment group he is the initiator
behind riga fiber and deutsche glass
father the success of this innovative
strategy has been confirmed by a reggae
fibers penetration in the market in the
Netherlands and its recent acquisition
by kpn the ftth Castle Europe individual
award is given to mr. dig vessels and I
would like to welcome on to the stage
mr. yan David's former director of
reggae fiber and nav director of reggae
borg big vessels family investment group
who will represent mr. dick vessels
ladies and gentlemen good morning on
behalf of mr. vessels first he would
like to apologize for not being able to
pick up the price himself secondly he's
very thankful and honored for receiving
this this price and the third one he
would like to mention is that success is
always a team effort without a good
management team without dedicated
employees rekha fiber or daughter glass
father could never never have been so
successful board of directors thank you
very much for awarding this price